i'm mark duploss and i play pretzel on
the new apple tv plus original series
pretzel and the puppies you guys are big
readers
join us for our pretzel read along story
time story time
[Music]
all right now i'm going to read pretzel
by margaret ray with pictures by h.a ray
one morning in may five little
dachshunds were born one of them was
pretzel look how cute he is
who sees pretzel which one is that's it
that is pretzel good that was impressive
come on puff paws up yeah they grew up
the way puppies do and they all looked
exactly the same for the first few weeks
but after nine weeks
pretzel
suddenly started growing
and growing and growing he grew much
longer than any of his brothers or
sisters and when he was fully grown he
had become the longest oxen in the world
what about us are we long enough pretzel
was very pleased with himself because it
is very distinguished for adoption to be
so long
i love it
when he was one year old a dachshund has
grown up at that age he won the blue
ribbon at the dog show which means that
everybody considered him the best
looking dog of all
all the dogs admired him and all the
people admired him too only greta didn't
it's tough when they don't love you back
greta was the little dachshund from
across the street pretzel was in love
with her you wanted to marry her
but greta well she just laughed at him i
don't care for long dogs she said wait
what but it is very distinguished for a
dachshund to be so long and i won the
blue ribbon at the dog show said pretzel
i still don't care said greta she still
doesn't care what what's it gonna take
oh
pretzel was hurt but he did not show it
please marry me he said please yes he
was begging please please marry me and i
will do anything for you he said
prove it said greta and went away
so pretzel set out to prove it now that
sure makes my tail wag
first he bought greta a nice bone you
guys like bones look at that bone yummy
bone
for me
thanks for the bone said greta but i
won't marry you for that i don't care
for long dogs
and she ate the bone
and then she kind of forgot about
pretzel well pretzel had to try
something else he gave her the lovely
green rubber ball he had been given for
his birthday thank you said greta
but i still won't marry you because i
don't care for long dogs besides
everybody can give presents
and she ran away
with the ball who would do that who
would do such a thing look what i can do
nobody except me can do that said
pretzel when they met again and this is
what he did
all right who can make a pretzel let's
see it kind of you do a little twisty
thing don't get yourself all tied up in
nuts
not bad said greta
your name certainly fits you but i like
pretzels at the baker's better
and i still don't care
for long dogs
pretzel is very unhappy some weeks had
passed and greta hadn't even spoken to
pretzel
one day while she was playing with her
green ball it bounced away look
greta tried to catch it and boom they
both landed in a hole can you believe it
it's scary what's gonna happen let's
figure it out okay okay we'll get there
i know you're excited you're literally
salivating to figure out what happens
next greta tried to get out of the hole
but she couldn't it was much too deep
she was terribly scared
if nobody came to save her she might
never
never
just then
pretzel's face appeared over the edge of
the hole i'll get you out of there he
shouted he had watched greta all the
time and now he rushed to help her
how good
that pretzel
was long
i believe you saved my life
you are wonderful said greta with a sigh
will you marry me now asked pretzel
what's gonna happen what's gonna i know
i know it's exciting i know
i will said greta but not for your
length
so they kissed each other and they got
married and one morning in may
five little dachshunds were born
look at the puppies look
[Music]
yeah it's you guys
the
end
want another story i mean when does it
end you're gonna have to watch the show
they can't get enough